harold je ne sais pas ce que tu penses que
tu fais ça excuse moi
bonjour  tu penses que ça va avoir des ennuis
ici
fais-moi une faveur essaie d'être optimiste
tu n'arrives pas ici
sans que les choses commencent il y a longtemps
alors deux soldats
et une infirmière se sont retrouvés à
amsterdam
nous avons formé le pacte et nous nous sommes juré de nous
protéger
non  peu importe ce que
nous nous retrouvons dans une situation où
nous sommes accusés d'avoir tué quelqu'un qui
n'est pas vrai
vous et le bûcheron avez fui la scène le
tueur nous a pointé du doigt nous n'avons
rien fait pourquoi pourriez-vous penser
que c'était nous
eh bien il n'y en a pas trop  des gens qui
correspondent à la description d'un médecin
cherchant son œil sur le sol avec son
avocat noir l'amour de la faculté de droit de columbia
est drôle nous avons besoin de quelqu'un pour nous aider
à trouver la vérité
mon ami a été tué à
cause de quelque chose de monstrueux qu'il
avait
vu c'est tout  s'avère être beaucoup
plus grand que n'importe lequel d'entre nous
tu vas devoir prendre mon exemple
pour sortir de ça
j'ai dû poignarder un gars j'ai dû frapper une dame
avec une brique une fois quoi
c'est une longue histoire mais avec vous deux ce
sera un gâteau  marcher
ce sont des moments dangereux tu
fais attention je suis sur le point de faire quelque chose qui pourrait
me coûter la vie
le coucou est dans le nid et le
coucou est sur le point d'être piégé
coucou
[Musique]
c'est l'une des plus belles innovations
de zurich ça supprime tout  la douleur les gars
comme moi on doit se tourner vers l'alcool la
morphine et ça peut mener à l'addiction
oh c'est rapide
[Musique]
toi